prostitution waffenhandel geldwäsche
alles außerhalb des stammes ist
feindesland
sie haben sehr sehr schnell gemerkt dass
die deutschen an zahl und dass man mit
dieser angst auch sehr viel geld hat und
wenn eine frau sich daran nicht hält da
gibt's keine gnade
[Musik]
die stadt berlin ist aufgeteilt unter
dem araber clans konstitution
waffenhandel geldwäsche schutzgeld
menschenhandel jeder hat sein
territorium beurteilen erpressung
aufschrift ohne geld läuft gar nichts
man kann sich sozusagen ein staat im
staate aufbauen
[Musik]
die arabische klaren sind es 1976 in
berlin es hin und es sind ja mehrere
familien gewesen wie aus dem bürgerkrieg
gekommen sind die sich auch kannten und
sich dann zusammen geschlossen haben in
wirklichkeit waren das oftmals leute die
aus der türkei kamen die aber einfach
ihre papiere weggeschmissen haben
[Musik]
das asylrecht damals war ganz großzügig
das heißt sie haben alle sofort
wohnungen bekommen sozialhilfe und dann
kleider und die ganze einrichtung der
wohnung haben sie auch mit sand bekommen
sie waren verteilt und fertigen neukölln
kreuzberg morbid schöneberg es gab
schulpflicht born geld kindergeld und
haben sich da zusammengefunden und
community gebildet was man heute
bezeichnet als parallelwelt
das war für sie wirklich ein paradies
[Musik]
die kleinkriminalität hat mit der
problematik der integration
beziehungsweise werden wir sind die das
für uns tun viele wollten ja studieren
wollten eine ausbildung machen und das
dürften sie nicht und irgendwie mussten
sie ja an geld kommen
ich habe nur eine duldung eine
aufenthaltsgenehmigung aber ihr habt
noch kein bleiberecht gar nix also
könnte hier auch nix machen und was
machen sie denn wenn sie jung sind heben
wollen auch ein gewisses polster habe zu
ihrer lebensart gehört das ist der
kriminalist gesagt haben okay wir wollen
ja auch irgendwo ein teil der
gesellschaft werden
dazu brauchen wir geld und haben ihre
art selber entwickelt sich geld zu
beschaffen
und sie haben sehr sehr schnell gemerkt
dass die deutschen angst haben und dass
man mit dieser angst auch sehr viel geld
verdienen kann
[Musik]
die wende war war für die clans
natürlich irgendwie die kriminalität ist
gestiegen weil viele aus dem ostblock
gekommen sind für zehn dosen die hier
den jungs in der kriminellen szene das
leben schwer gemacht haben und wir
stellten fest dass gerade junge männer
dann nicht sehr zimperlich waren wenn
wir von clans sprechen dann meinen wir
den kriminellen teil ein prozentual
kleiner anteil solcher großen familien
diese klaren die waren bereit zu
schießen aber die deutschen kriminellen
wann sich bereit zu schießen und das
haben sie gemacht und das haben sie sehr
erfolgreich gemacht sich durchgesetzt
gegen höher den ostblock den russen und
ihre gebiete übernommen und letztendlich
auch komplett von den deutschen
[Musik]
sie haben dann ruckzuck englisch das
umfeld von von drogengeschäften
übernommen prostitution waffenhandel
geldwäsche schutzgeld menschenhandel
überfälle erpressung rauschgift das ding
ist ja auch eine tür interessant macht
wie war das dazu in vielen clubs und
daher sind türen sehr wichtig
[Musik]
na das war damals zum beispiel so an wer
den club der sehr bekannt sehr groß war
und man hat dann ausländer hingeschickt
die vorne stress gemacht
masih stress also schwere schlägereien
und messerstechereien so dass dann
besuchern von einem dieser stress machen
gesagt haben man ich habe gehört der
plätze war stress gehabt und wir sind
hier in wedding hier sind da noch sehr
viele migranten und das ist doch besser
wenn ihr jemanden von uns mit anna türen
und dann habt ihr erheblich weniger
probleme
denn bei einer mit einer tür aber der
hat er natürlich seine der ganzen
freunde auch rein geholt und hat dann
erklärt die müssen auch da sehen falls
irgend eine andere gruppe kommt eine
andere gruppierung an makler müssen wir
uns verteidigen
deswegen sind auch immer mehr
familienangehörige dazu gekommen und da
war die stimmung nicht so gut und
regelmäßig waren schlägerei
[Applaus]
das hat dazu geführt haben dass der klub
zu gemacht hat dann kam neuer inhaber
der den laden aufgemacht mit den namen
palace ich habe die tür übernommen und
hatte natürlich auch gespräche mit clans
die gesagt haben wie hier waren eine tür
und wir würden gerne hier wieder mit an
der tür arbeiten und ich habe ganz klar
gesagt funktioniert das nicht ich habe
eine ganz andere politik als andere
vielleicht am türsteher bereit
ich mache alles komplett zu 100 prozent
mit der polizei und das hat geklappt bis
heute habe ich diese politik durchsetzen
können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die stadt berlin ist aufgeteilt unter
dem araber clans und jeder hat sein
territorium die wichtigsten namen denke
ich mal sind seien mehrere familien die
apothekerfamilie immer die familie rath
die familie ali khan welcher familie zu
familie cut pro familie in berlin hat
man es etwa somit immer um die 20
familien zu tun
im zusammenhang mit dieser thematik
stellt nur köln natürlich einen gewissen
brennpunkte a beziehungsweise bestimmte
teile von neukölln ich bin auch aus
diesen familien heraus niemals bedroht
worden im gegenteil ich war immer ein
liebgewordenes opfer zum self machen man
lud mich auch gerne zum teetrinken nach
hause zu kommen ein habe ich nie gemacht
mein eindruck war immer dass die
familien schon wert darauf legten ein
entspanntes verhältnis zum bürgermeister
zu haben im bis hin zur ausgesprochen
und gegen ansprachen von jungen
halbwüchsigen männern nach dem motto
bürgermeister hast du feinde sagt
bescheid wir kämpfen für dich
[Musik]
jede familie hat ihr territorium in dem
sie das sagen hat und man sieht
eigentlich zu sich nicht ins gehege zu
kommen die wirtschaft hat sich geändert
das heißt früher war es lokal in ihrem
wohngebiet größtenteils war es sehr
problematischen wedding kreuzberg
neukölln auch schöneberg hatte gegen die
problematisch waren nur bietet jetzt mit
den neuen techniken und mit der
geldwäsche versuchen sie neue gebiete zu
erholen also wie zuletzt zum beispiel
diese messerstecherei in charlottenburg
am alten platz zeigt dass sie jetzt
überall sind die leute die die meiste
kohle haben den besitzen auch macht und
ansehen jener stadt ohne geld läuft gar
nichts und wenn man dieses geld dann in
berlin entsprechend anlegt
beispielsweise in immobilien das ist
gerade jetzt im moment unheimlich in
dann kann man damit eben reichtum und
einfluss haben man kann sich also dann
aussuchen wer zieht da in meiner häuser
ein mann kann sich sozusagen eine ein
staat im staate aufbauen und genau auf
diesem wege sind diese arabischen
großfamilien
[Musik]
alles außerhalb des stammes ist
feindesland die familien akzeptieren die
deutsche strafjustiz und auch die
deutsche polizei nicht als übergeordnete
instanz sondern sie sehen sie schon auf
einer ebene und sie sehen es als einen
ständigen kampf wer der stärkste ist
wenn irgendwas passiert in der familie
guten schlägerei irgendwelche reihe dann
müssen plötzlich alle irgendwo mithelfen
[Applaus]
man muss auch nicht vergessen dass es
mit der altfallregelung viele die
deutsche staatsangehörigkeit besitzen
also ich schätze ihn über die helfer von
denen mindestens die gehören total zu
und man kann sie nicht abschieben
[Musik]
es gibt in diesen clans gibt es
natürlich einen inneren kern der festes
wo man kaum ran kommen kann und dann
gibt's den äußeren kreis die zugezogen
zu geheiratet oder fußsoldaten sind es
gibt da verschiedene levels von
mitgliedern sagen wir mal die
unterdrückung der frau spielt eine
entscheidende rolle in der plan struktur
zu der schwerpunkt der klaren struktur
ist wie endo grammy ein wichtiges
element
damit man unter sich bleiben mit der
cousine
also es gab immer wieder die berichte
dass frauen bei wichtigen entscheidungen
das familienrat den raum zu verlassen
haben dass sie gern noch einen tee
kochen durften aber dann hatten sie
auszugehen
mir ist auch nicht bekannt dass frauen
mit zugegen sein durften wenn
familiengericht gehalten wurde
zwangsehen sind die regel bei den clans
mit minderjährigen sind die regeln also
ab 14 ist man schon so weit weil den
menschen und sie müssen heiraten und
kinder erzeuge und das läuft ohne den
zwang nicht und wenn eine versicherung
schnell da gibt es keine gnade ein
wichtiger punkt der uns gelingen muss um
in der zukunft erfolgreich zu sein ist
es natürlich die kinder und die
jugendlichen in den blick zu nehmen weil
wir hier noch chancen haben sie
tatsächlich herauszubekommen aus diesen
strukturen
insoweit sind sowohl die frauen als auch
die kinder für die präventionsarbeit
ganz große zielgruppe da man sich einmal
ende ist mit clans geschäftlich da kommt
man da ganz ganz schweres oder gar nicht
sehr schwer ich da zu lösen es gibt auch
andere
wir haben die möglichkeit hier auch in
berlin in deutschland zu leben hut zu
nehmen ohne kriminell zu sein und viele
viele bauten also aber die sagen dieser
familien sowieso familien druck da kann
man sich manchmal in time wenn man dort
groß geworden ist schwer denn ziehen was
machst du als 25-jähriger der keinen
abschluss hat keine auswirkung hat kein
studium hat und die leute um dich herum
die geld machen machen es mal
hingegangen weiß was machst du
[Musik]
die deutschen gesetze und die
lebensregeln auch nicht besser hier eine
roma schenkel stechen normale zeugen die
bekannt sind bei den anwälten die
kriegen dann mitunter hausbesuche wo
klar gemacht wird und du siehst du die
aussage durch das team nicht mehr
glücklich
in einem fall hat ja auch ein sek
beamter das mit dem leben bezahlt
[Musik]